playing the bizarre peculiar roles to
this team this year
well he's unproven as Thompson accident
in that he played very limited in
Sacramento so their defense is going to
have to be excellent if they win over 25
games as Thompson Matson another well
buddy he'll get stuck on the screen
Thompson with a lot of times and for him
it works out perfectly go to the team
where he doesn't have to play by the way
and they're not concerned as Thompson
knocks down the 3-pointer IELTS also
selected last year just a lot of talent
it's so young quite time to the hot hand
early on it's his pork beer ball already
badly goes at the ranch shot blocked and
that's what Damian Jones that
athleticism Thompson waits Thompson
getting the crowd fired up Brett hopped
here to start the first quarter and then
the Semite transition they don't
identify Thompson and he makes them pay
and continue to improve when they're
only surrounded by young players I mean
that to me is one of the reasons I'd
like to see some guys
[Applause]
drinks cookies also come on for the
first Thompson's jump shots so smooth
tonight
that's a big-time shot sort of Ward's
off Justin Jackson to create space